all right great to be back at it
audience questions missed three last
week because of the vacation but I'm
back and these are good ones first
question hey David what's the worst that
could really happen with a Bernie or
Warren presidency anyway Republicans are
pretending like it could be the end of
the world what are people actually
afraid of are things so good right now
that Bernie or Warren might ruin
everything
did this is very astute when we think of
the policies that somebody like Bernie
or Warren would put in place what is the
worst that could happen
right I mean listen there's the idea
Democrats won't protect us because
they're too scared to use the military
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
unlike Donald Trump don't believe that
they are the most knowledgeable people
in the room on every issue all the time
they would follow the recommendations of
the military and intelligence community
they would meet whatever threats our
intelligence community and the Pentagon
and the Defense Department present to
them period the idea that they are going
to say no were we're gonna do nothing
and let people just come on that that
that can't seriously be something any
thinking person believes is a risk
number two they'll ruin the economy
they're gonna blow up the debt like
every other president has done other
than Barack Obama who actually slowed
down the growth of the national debt
historically employment does better
under Democratic presidents than
Republican presidents the stock market
does better under Democratic presidents
than Republican presidents there is no
evidence whatsoever to suggest that we
should be worried and as far as debt
goes the debt has been exploding for how
long has it been exploding the more we
understand about debt including modern
monetary theory we understand that just
debt in and of itself just the number
doesn't tell us whether the economy is
doing poorly or well or whether the
president is doing a good or a bad job
why are we deficit spending is it
economically stimulative if we are going
to deficit spend if it was necessary to
make sure everybody has health care that
would be worth it because people who are
healthy work more they earn more money
they generate more tax revenue for the
government so again the fears of a
Democrat will destroy the economy
are completely unfounded and so the
worst case scenario of Bernie being
president or Warren being president will
have more respect from other countries
around the world we will finally start
making sense when it comes to foreign
policy and trade policy and whatever
else the worst case is some of the
programs that Bernie or Warren want to
do might end up not completely paying
for themselves and then we'll have a
little bit more debt like we do with
every president I mean I mean I'm being
sort of facetious but also not I mean
this that you're asking the question in
the exact right way
what is the nightmare scenario of a
Bernie or Warren presidency there is no
such nightmare scenario we're in the
nightmare scenario right down right now
and I think it was Trump who said didn't
Trump say to black people why not vote
for me I mean things haven't been going
so well for you guys anyway have the
status quo Center left to center-right
presidents we've had really been working
out that well for everybody other than
the richest I think the numbers make it
pretty clear so yeah it's good that
you're being skeptical of this idea that
Bernie ER and Warren as president are
going to somehow destroy our way of life
and everything that we hold dear doesn't
make any sense the facts don't bear it
out don't even worry about that